This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）主持的《迎难而上》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.|||在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《迎难而上》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.|||这就是可以在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听的《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.|||他会得到应有的惩罚。我们常说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回首往事》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to dive into something that can be quite unsettling. We're going to discuss the psychology of dissociation. Now, you may have heard of this, you may have experienced this. It is this disconnect we have at times between our reality and ourselves. It's this feeling where like, a weird, blurry screen almost goes up between you and the world.
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to dive into something that can be quite unsettling. We're going to discuss the psychology of dissociation. Now, you may have heard of this, you may have experienced this. It is this disconnect we have at times between our reality and ourselves. It's this feeling where like, a weird, blurry screen almost goes up between you and the world.|||大家好，欢迎回到《20岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化与转变及其对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎新老听众回到本播客。无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们将剖析20多岁的心理学。今天，我们要深入探讨一件可能会让人感到相当不安的事情。我们将讨论解离（dissociation）的心理学。现在，你可能听说过这个词，也可能经历过这种感觉。这是我们在现实与自我之间有时会产生的这种脱节感。这种感觉就像是，你和世界之间几乎升起了一道奇怪而模糊的屏幕。
And let's be just completely honest, straight off the bat. It is super scary. It's honestly really terrifying. And it's also deeply misunderstood. And something that because it feels so terrifying, we don't talk about because we think it's going to validate the thoughts that we have about the experience. And that actually means that the panic that we feel or the stress becomes a lot stronger. When I say dissociation, I want you to think of a very old, very dramatic survival
And let's be just completely honest, straight off the bat. It is super scary. It's honestly really terrifying. And it's also deeply misunderstood. And something that because it feels so terrifying, we don't talk about because we think it's going to validate the thoughts that we have about the experience. And that actually means that the panic that we feel or the stress becomes a lot stronger. When I say dissociation, I want you to think of a very old, very dramatic survival|||坦白讲，开门见山地说。这超级可怕。老实说，这真的很吓人。而且它也常常被严重误解。正因为它感觉如此可怕，我们才不去谈论它，因为我们认为这会证实我们对这种经历的想法。而这实际上意味着我们感到的恐慌或压力会变得更加强烈。当我说到解离时，我希望你想到一种非常古老、非常戏剧性的生存。
strategy that our brain has. It is this ability that we all have to disconnect from our thoughts, our feelings, our surroundings, when things get really overwhelming. Now, because it's automatic, that's why we have a lot of confusion and fear towards the sensations that it brings up, even though it's not actually a sign always of anything actually going wrong within our brains and within our psychology. This is something that I think is really helpful to understand if you have been experiencing dissociation recently, sometimes dip into this state of mind. It doesn't necessarily mean that you are going so called crazy, that you are losing your mind, that you are losing touch with reality.
strategy that our brain has. It is this ability that we all have to disconnect from our thoughts, our feelings, our surroundings, when things get really overwhelming. Now, because it's automatic, that's why we have a lot of confusion and fear towards the sensations that it brings up, even though it's not actually a sign always of anything actually going wrong within our brains and within our psychology. This is something that I think is really helpful to understand if you have been experiencing dissociation recently, sometimes dip into this state of mind. It doesn't necessarily mean that you are going so called crazy, that you are losing your mind, that you are losing touch with reality.|||策略，这是我们的大脑所拥有的。当事情变得真正让人无法承受时，我们所有人都有这种能力，能够与我们的想法、感觉和周围环境断开连接。现在，因为它是一个自动的过程，这就是为什么我们会对它带来的感觉产生许多困惑和恐惧，尽管它实际上并不总是表明我们的大脑和心理出了什么问题。如果你最近一直在经历解离，有时会陷入这种精神状态，我认为了解这一点真的很有帮助。这并不一定意味着你所谓的疯了，意味着你失去了理智，或者你与现实失去了联系。
There are a lot of other explanations that I think are really helpful just to know about. So that's what we're going to talk about today. We're going to talk about why it happens, what it is. Most importantly as well, what you can actually do when your brain kind of seems to stop being sure of whether you're here or not. Because you most certainly are. I can promise you that. You are here.
There are a lot of other explanations that I think are really helpful just to know about. So that's what we're going to talk about today. We're going to talk about why it happens, what it is. Most importantly as well, what you can actually do when your brain kind of seems to stop being sure of whether you're here or not. Because you most certainly are. I can promise you that. You are here.|||还有许多其他的解释，我认为了解这些会非常有帮助。所以这就是我们今天要讨论的内容。我们要讨论它为什么会发生，它是什么。同样最重要的是，当你的大脑似乎不再确定你是否在这里时，你实际上可以做些什么。因为你百分之百在这里。我向你保证。你在这里。
You are alive. The world is real. You just need to find ways to get back in touch. with the parts of your brain that will help you believe that. We have quite a science-packed episode today for you guys, which I know a lot of you love. And sometimes I think with something as irrational as dissociation, like the only real, like, counterweight is just to hit it with like a fistful of reason and rationality. And that's hopefully what we're going to do.
You are alive. The world is real. You just need to find ways to get back in touch. with the parts of your brain that will help you believe that. We have quite a science-packed episode today for you guys, which I know a lot of you love. And sometimes I think with something as irrational as dissociation, like the only real, like, counterweight is just to hit it with like a fistful of reason and rationality. And that's hopefully what we're going to do.|||你还活着。这个世界是真实的。你只需要找到方法重新联系上大脑中能帮你相信这一点的部分。今天我们有一期充满科学干货的节目送给大家，我知道你们很多人都很喜欢。有时我认为，对于像解离这样毫无理性可言的事情，唯一的真正的“对立面”就是用一把理智和理性去对抗它。希望这正是我们要做的。
I also want to talk about my own experience with this. I literally had a moment like this last night. and there are a couple of strategies that I always use that I find pretty fullproof that I want to also kind of let you guys in on as well to hopefully help you in these like scary moments. So you're going to get the personal insights. You're also going to get the scientific background, the perfect combination if you ask me. Without further ado, let's get into the psychology of dissociation. Start super simple.
I also want to talk about my own experience with this. I literally had a moment like this last night. and there are a couple of strategies that I always use that I find pretty fullproof that I want to also kind of let you guys in on as well to hopefully help you in these like scary moments. So you're going to get the personal insights. You're also going to get the scientific background, the perfect combination if you ask me. Without further ado, let's get into the psychology of dissociation. Start super simple.|||我还想谈谈我自己的经历。我昨晚确实经历了这样一个时刻。我有一些自己经常使用、觉得非常万无一失的策略，我也想向大家透露一点，希望能在这类可怕的时刻帮到你们。所以，你将听到个人的见解。你还将获得科学背景，如果你问我，这是完美的组合。闲话少说，让我们进入解离的心理学。从超级简单的地方开始。
Dissociation is one of those words that floats around a lot. in mental health conversations, but it is, of course, often misunderstood. Honestly, at this stage, like, what term isn't misunderstood? But I always feel the need to just give like a bare minimum definition at the beginning, even if you've heard of the thing we're talking about before. So in psychology, dissociation refers to basically a disruption in the normal integration of consciousness, memory, identity, emotion, and perception. In other words, it's what happens when parts of our mental experience, our thoughts, our awareness,
Dissociation is one of those words that floats around a lot. in mental health conversations, but it is, of course, often misunderstood. Honestly, at this stage, like, what term isn't misunderstood? But I always feel the need to just give like a bare minimum definition at the beginning, even if you've heard of the thing we're talking about before. So in psychology, dissociation refers to basically a disruption in the normal integration of consciousness, memory, identity, emotion, and perception. In other words, it's what happens when parts of our mental experience, our thoughts, our awareness,|||解离是心理健康对话中经常流传的一个词，但它当然也常常被误解。说实话，在这个阶段，哪个术语没有被误解过呢？但我总是觉得有必要在开头给出一个最低限度的定义，即使你以前听说过我们正在谈论的事物。因此，在心理学中，解离基本上是指意识、记忆、身份、情绪和感知正常整合的中断。换句话说，这就是当我们的心理体验、我们的思想、我们的觉知的一部分发生时所发生的情况，
our connection to our body or the world around us, it just kind of stops lining up in the ways that it usually would. And it's often because we are avoiding some kind of emotional information or emotional pain to protect our fragile psyche. Our sense of continuity, this thing that, you know, joins ourselves, that joins time, our actions, the world around us, into one singular thing and singular experience, that becomes fractured. And we feel that fracturing as intense discomfort, anxiety, but also like there is a fuzziness to our experiences that, you know, maybe we're not really here or the world around us isn't here
our connection to our body or the world around us, it just kind of stops lining up in the ways that it usually would. And it's often because we are avoiding some kind of emotional information or emotional pain to protect our fragile psyche. Our sense of continuity, this thing that, you know, joins ourselves, that joins time, our actions, the world around us, into one singular thing and singular experience, that becomes fractured. And we feel that fracturing as intense discomfort, anxiety, but also like there is a fuzziness to our experiences that, you know, maybe we're not really here or the world around us isn't here|||我们与身体或周围世界的联系，只是不再像平时那样保持一致了。这通常是因为我们在回避某种情感信息或情感痛苦，以保护我们脆弱的心理。我们的连续感，这个你知道的，将我们自己、时间、我们的行为、我们周围的世界连结成一个单一的事物和单一体验的东西，开始破裂了。我们将这种破裂感体验为强烈的不适、焦虑，同时也觉得我们的体验有一种模糊感，你知道的，也许我们并不真的在这里，或者我们周围的世界并不在这里
either. Now, both of these things being here and the world existing are pretty fundamental to our sense of psychological stability. That is probably the understatement of a lifetime. And that's why this creates so much terror. It's not because those things are true. It's because the possibility of them being true makes us feel like we don't really know anything. Pierre-Jane, he was a French psychologist writing in the late 19th century. He was actually one of the first two start to describe dissociation, and he described it as a breakdown in the mind's integrative capacity. And what he essentially concluded when he was looking at patients, he was looking at people with extreme trauma, was that when stress or trauma overwhelms us, the brain breaks up how it experiences that in
either. Now, both of these things being here and the world existing are pretty fundamental to our sense of psychological stability. That is probably the understatement of a lifetime. And that's why this creates so much terror. It's not because those things are true. It's because the possibility of them being true makes us feel like we don't really know anything. Pierre-Jane, he was a French psychologist writing in the late 19th century. He was actually one of the first two start to describe dissociation, and he described it as a breakdown in the mind's integrative capacity. And what he essentially concluded when he was looking at patients, he was looking at people with extreme trauma, was that when stress or trauma overwhelms us, the brain breaks up how it experiences that in|||也是如此。现在，这两件事——我们在这里以及世界的存在——对于我们的心理稳定感来说是相当基础的。这大概是此生最轻描淡写的说法了。这就是为什么这会产生如此大的恐惧。这并不是因为这些事情是真的。而是因为它们可能是真的这种可能性让我们觉得我们其实什么都不知道。皮埃尔·雅内（Pierre Janet），他是19世纪末写作的法国心理学家。他实际上是最早开始描述解离的人之一，他将其描述为心灵整合能力的崩溃。当他观察患者（他当时在观察患有极度创伤的人）时，他本质上得出的结论是，当压力或创伤压倒我们时，大脑会将它体验这种经历的方式打碎，
order to protect deeper parts of ourselves. It is our brain, as he says, trying to survive hard things so that our soul suffers less. That's one explanation. It is not, as some movies would suggest, someone flipping into a completely different person without more. morning. Like, it does not make you dangerous. It is also not the same thing as psychosis. Dissociation can feel strange and it can feel scary and floaty. It doesn't mean that you're losing touch with reality in a psychotic sense. It doesn't also mean that you may be having delusions or hallucinations that could or maybe would indicate a more serious diagnosis like schizophrenia, for example. A lot of other things have to be present and happening for that to be considered. Dissociation cannot be your only
order to protect deeper parts of ourselves. It is our brain, as he says, trying to survive hard things so that our soul suffers less. That's one explanation. It is not, as some movies would suggest, someone flipping into a completely different person without more. morning. Like, it does not make you dangerous. It is also not the same thing as psychosis. Dissociation can feel strange and it can feel scary and floaty. It doesn't mean that you're losing touch with reality in a psychotic sense. It doesn't also mean that you may be having delusions or hallucinations that could or maybe would indicate a more serious diagnosis like schizophrenia, for example. A lot of other things have to be present and happening for that to be considered. Dissociation cannot be your only|||以保护我们更深层的自我。正如他所说，这是我们的大脑在试图在艰难的事情中生存下来，好让我们的灵魂少受点苦。这是一种解释。正如某些电影所暗示的那样，它并不是指某人突然变成了一个完全不同的人，毫无征兆。就像，它不会让你变得危险。它也与精神病（psychosis）不是同一回事。解离可能会让人觉得奇怪，觉得可怕且飘忽不定。这并不意味着你在精神病的意义上与现实失去了联系。这也不意味着你可能会产生妄想或幻觉，这些可能表明更严重的诊断，例如精神分裂症。必须有很多其他的事情同时存在并发生，才能被认为是那样。解离不能是你的唯一
symptom. You know, psychosis, you have to be delusional. You have to really, like, not be able to question the fact that maybe what you're thinking is wrong. Dissociation, though, there is, like, a part of you that knows that this probably isn't real and that can recognize that this is some kind of split. And it's a defense mechanism. They definitely overlap at times. But I just feel the need to address this because it's a common fear that I've had and that I know other people have had that they're dissociating, they're feeling super weird, super unreal, and they think that maybe this is a sign of something a lot more serious to do with their mental stability, that they are developing schizophrenia, that they are going into a psychotic
symptom. You know, psychosis, you have to be delusional. You have to really, like, not be able to question the fact that maybe what you're thinking is wrong. Dissociation, though, there is, like, a part of you that knows that this probably isn't real and that can recognize that this is some kind of split. And it's a defense mechanism. They definitely overlap at times. But I just feel the need to address this because it's a common fear that I've had and that I know other people have had that they're dissociating, they're feeling super weird, super unreal, and they think that maybe this is a sign of something a lot more serious to do with their mental stability, that they are developing schizophrenia, that they are going into a psychotic|||症状。你知道的，精神病，你必须有妄想。你必须真的，比如，无法去质疑这样一个事实：也许你的想法是错的。然而，解离则不同，你内心深处会有一个部分知道这可能不是真的，并且能够认识到这是一种某种程度上的分裂。这是一种防御机制。它们有时肯定会有所重叠。但我只是觉得有必要谈谈这一点，因为这是我曾有过的共同恐惧，我也知道其他人也有过这种恐惧，即他们正在解离，感觉超级奇怪、超级不真实，他们认为这可能是某种与他们的心理稳定性有关的更严重问题的征兆，意味着他们正在患上精神分裂症，意味着他们正在陷入精神病
episode. The majority of the time, I can promise you that is not the case. Now, dissociation also exists on a spectrum. And the other thing that's important to know is that pretty much everyone will experience some level of this in their life. Maybe that's comforting to you. You know, at one end of the spectrum, the most extreme end, we have dissociative identity disorder, also known as multiple personality disorder. That is like the most extreme version of this.
episode. The majority of the time, I can promise you that is not the case. Now, dissociation also exists on a spectrum. And the other thing that's important to know is that pretty-much everyone will experience some level of this in their life. Maybe that's comforting to you. You know, at one end of the spectrum, the most extreme end, we have dissociative identity disorder, also known as multiple personality disorder. That is like the most extreme version of this.|||发作。大多数时候，我向你保证，事实并非如此。现在，解离也是存在于一个光谱上的。另一件需要知道的重要事情是，几乎每个人一生中都会经历某种程度的解离。这或许能给你带来一些安慰。你知道，在光谱的一端，也就是最极端的一端，我们有解离性身份障碍（dissociative identity disorder），也被称为多重人格障碍。那就像是这东西最极端的版本。
But for most people, the everyday experience of dissociation is, is just, you know, blanking out during a stressful conversation, losing a few minutes, feeling disconnected during exam season, after a breakup, during a really hard day. Now, you've probably heard of depersonalization as well and derealization. These are basically forms of dissociation that people may experience differently. So we have dissociation as like the blanket idea of feeling disconnected, feeling like there's a lack of continuity. Then we have underneath that depersonalization.
But for most people, the everyday experience of dissociation is, is just, you know, blanking out during a stressful conversation, losing a few minutes, feeling disconnected during exam season, after a breakup, during a really hard day. Now, you've probably heard of depersonalization as well and derealization. These are basically forms of dissociation that people may experience differently. So we have dissociation as like the blanket idea of feeling disconnected, feeling like there's a lack of continuity. Then we have underneath that depersonalization.|||但对大多数人来说，日常的解离体验就是，你知道的，在压力重重的对话中大脑一片空白，走神几分钟，在考试季、失恋后或度过艰难的一天时感到脱节。现在，你可能也听说过人格解体（depersonalization）和现实解体（derealization）。这些基本上是人们可能会以不同方式体验到的解离形式。因此，我们有将解离作为一种笼统的概念，即感到脱节、感觉缺乏连续性。然后在这个概念之下，我们有人格解体。
And this is when this feeling of being disconnected is feeling disconnected from your own body or your own thoughts, like you're kind of watching yourself from the outside. In this form, you don't feel real. The world feels real. You're seeing things happen to you and to your life or your environment. You just don't feel it.
And this is when this feeling of being disconnected is feeling disconnected from your own body or your own thoughts, like you're kind of watching yourself from the outside. In this form, you don't feel real. The world feels real. You're seeing things happen to you and to your life or your environment. You just don't feel it.|||这就是当这种脱节感表现为与你自己的身体或你自己的思想脱节时，就像你正在从外部观察自己一样。在这种形式下，你感觉不到自己是真实的。世界感觉是真实的。你看到事情发生在你身上、你的生活或你的环境中。你只是感觉不到它。
Then there's de-realization. And that's when the world seems fake. but you feel real. The world feels colorless, flat, dreamlike, you know you exist, but there's all these questions of like, how can I be sure that what I'm seeing and observing isn't just a figment of my imagination? Obviously, that's quite existential and it can really make you feel detached from the world around you. It's not always cause for concern. Some other forms of this that you may see or hear discussed are dissociative amnesia. This is a lot less common. It's when you can't recall personal information, especially around like traumatic or highly stressful events in your life.
Then there's de-realization. And that's when the world seems fake. but you feel real. The world feels colorless, flat, dreamlike, you know you exist, but there's all these questions of like, how can I be sure that what I'm seeing and observing isn't just a figment of my imagination? Obviously, that's quite existential and it can really make you feel detached from the world around you. It's not always cause for concern. Some other forms of this that you may see or hear discussed are dissociative amnesia. This is a lot less common. It's when you can't recall personal information, especially around like traumatic or highly stressful events in your life.|||然后是现实解体。那是当世界看起来是假的，但你觉得真实的时候。世界感觉索然无味、扁平、如梦似幻，你知道自己存在，但有所有这些问题，比如，我怎么能确定我所看到和观察到的不只是我自己的想象呢？显然，这相当具有存在主义色彩，并且真的会让你感到与周围的世界隔绝。这并不总是需要担心的原因。你可能会看到或听到讨论的其他形式包括解离性遗忘症（dissociative amnesia）。这要少见得多。它是指你无法回忆起个人信息，尤其是关于你生活中创伤性或高度应激事件的信息。
Clinicians will also talk about perit traumatic dissociation, which is kind of similar. It's like the kind of dissociation that happens right after a traumatic event and also chronic dissociation, which is when this detached state exists long after the triggering event has occurred. And then just to circle all the way back, because I feel like I didn't give it enough attention, we have dissociative identity disorder. This is the idea that when someone goes through something really terrible, their personality can literally split so that they are, they completely dissociate from who they are and all of their thoughts and feelings become contained by another personality.
Clinicians will also talk about perit traumatic dissociation, which is kind of similar. It's like the kind of dissociation that happens right after a traumatic event and also chronic dissociation, which is when this detached state exists long after the triggering event has occurred. And then just to circle all the way back, because I feel like I didn't give it enough attention, we have dissociative identity disorder. This is the idea that when someone goes through something really terrible, their personality can literally split so that they are, they completely dissociate from who they are and all of their thoughts and feelings become contained by another personality.|||临床医生还会谈到围创伤期解离（peri-traumatic dissociation），这有点类似。它就像是发生在创伤事件之后的解离，还有慢性解离（chronic dissociation），即这种疏离状态在触发事件发生后很久仍然存在。然后绕回最初的话题，因为我觉得之前没有给予它足够的关注，我们有解离性身份障碍。这是这样一种观点：当某人经历了一些非常糟糕的事情时，他们的人格实际上会分裂，以至于他们完全与自己是谁解离了，他们所有的思想和感受都被另一个人格所包含。
This is extremely rare. And it's even worth noting that its existence is even disputed by some. I definitely think that it exists. Like, there's definitely, there are so many cases of this happening. But we're going to talk more about that later and how and when that develops within somebody. Most of the time, what you will be experiencing is just everyday dissociation. This is what happens when, you know, you're driving home from work and you don't remember the last 10 minutes. Or you're zoning out during a conversation or like you blink in an hour is past.
This is extremely rare. And it's even worth noting that its existence is even disputed by some. I definitely think that it exists. Like, there's definitely, there are so many cases of this happening. But we're going to talk more about that later and how and when that develops within somebody. Most of the time, what you will be experiencing is just everyday dissociation. This is what happens when, you know, you're driving home from work and you don't remember the last 10 minutes. Or you're zoning out during a conversation or like you blink in an hour is passed.|||这极其罕见。甚至值得注意的是，它的存在甚至还受到某些人的质疑。我绝对认为它是存在的。比如，肯定有，有很多这样的案例发生。但我们稍后会对此进行更多讨论，以及它如何在某人身上发展以及何时发展。大多数时候，你所经历的只是日常的解离。这就是当你，你知道的，开车下班回家却不记得最后10分钟发生了什么时所发生的事情。或者你在谈话时走神了，或者就像你眨眼间一个小时就过去了。
It's like you go into some kind of trance. sometimes it's called highway hypnosis or white line fever, especially like when you're driving. You can just see that there are very different levels of this feeling. And I think that's really crucial to understand so that we don't experience dissociation and suddenly think that we're going to split into a completely different person. Sometimes it's just because you're tired or you're stressed or, you know, from a myriad of other factors you're experiencing this. You have to understand that this is actually your brain doing exactly what it has evolved to do,
It's like you go into some kind of trance. sometimes it's called highway hypnosis or white line fever, especially like when you're driving. You can just see that there are very different levels of this feeling. And I think that's really crucial to understand so that we don't experience dissociation and suddenly think that we're going to split into a completely different person. Sometimes it's just because you're tired or you're stressed or, you know, from a myriad of other factors you're experiencing this. You have to understand that this is actually your brain doing exactly what it has evolved to do,|||这就像你进入了某种精神恍惚状态。有时这被称为高速公路催眠（highway hypnosis）或白线热（white line fever），特别是在你开车的时候。你可以看出这种感觉有着非常不同的层级。我认为理解这一点至关重要，这样当我们经历解离时，就不会突然觉得自己要分裂成一个完全不同的人了。有时这只是因为你累了，或者你压力很大，或者你知道，由于其他无数的因素，你才经历了这一切。你必须明白，这其实是你的人脑在做它进化而来的本职工作，
which is protect you. No matter how scary or shocking it is, at its core, this is just a coping mechanism. Even if it's made life feel very nonlinear or blurry or odd, you will come back. Your brain is just going a little bit too far. And I know that my brain does this for everything, right? my brain loves to do things at 150% whether it comes to love, whether it comes to ambition, perfectionism, anxiety, and it also does that with dissociation. It just takes it too far. This is really often in response to some kind of threat that we have either been able to consciously
which is protect you. No matter how scary or shocking it is, at its core, this is just a coping mechanism. Even if it's made life feel very nonlinear or blurry or odd, you will come back. Your brain is just going a little bit too far. And I know that my brain does this for everything, right? my brain loves to do things at 150% whether it comes to love, whether it comes to ambition, perfectionism, anxiety, and it also does that with dissociation. It just takes it too far. This is really often in response to some kind of threat that we have either been able to consciously|||那就是保护你。无论它多么可怕或令人震惊，其核心这只是一种应对机制。即使它让生活感觉非常非线性、模糊或奇怪，你也会回来的。你的人脑只是做得有点过头了。我知道我的大脑对每件事都这样，对吧？我的大脑喜欢以150%的力度做事，无论是对待爱情、野心、完美主义、焦虑，它对解离也是如此。它只是做得太过火了。这通常是对某种威胁的回应，这种威胁我们要么已经能够有意识地
detect or not. So according to what we know as polyvagal theory, our nervous system when it sees or encounters a threat follows a bit of a hierarchy. First, we feel the urge to fight, then flight, so then run away. And if neither of those is possible, if the danger feels inescapable, the body will shift into a free state or a shutdown state. Dissociation is what is linked to that last pathway. It's also sometimes called the dorsal vagal state. Vagal meaning vagal nerve.
detect or not. So according to what we know as polyvagal theory, our nervous system when it sees or encounters a threat follows a bit of a hierarchy. First, we feel the urge to fight, then flight, so then run away. And if neither of those is possible, if the danger feels inescapable, the body will shift into a free state or a shutdown state. Dissociation is what is linked to that last pathway. It's also sometimes called the dorsal vagal state. Vagal meaning vagal nerve.|||察觉到，要么没有。因此，根据我们所知道的多重迷走神经理论（polyvagal theory），我们的神经系统在看到或遇到威胁时，会遵循一定的层级。首先，我们会感到战斗的冲动，然后是逃跑（flight），也就是逃走。如果这两者都不可能实现，如果危险让人感觉无法逃脱，身体就会转入冷冻状态或关闭状态。解离就是与最后这条通路相连的东西。它有时也被称为背侧迷走神经状态（dorsal vagal state）。迷走神经意味着迷走神经。
this is the body's longest nerve. It's the main pathway for regulating almost every system in our body, specifically our parasympathetic nervous system, which slows things down, shuts things off. So when we experience dissociation, that state is triggered. And that is what's creating this narrowing of awareness, this kind of detachment, lack of focus. It's what causes our heart rate to drop. It's your nervous system basically saying, if I can't, escape this, if I can't fight back against this, I'll just disconnect. And maybe I'll survive with a few less emotional scars, or at least with some energy for later. When we look at the brain, neuroimaging studies will show that something fascinating happens during this process. When people
this is the body's longest nerve. It's the main pathway for regulating almost every system in our body, specifically our parasympathetic nervous system, which slows things down, shuts things off. So when we experience dissociation, that state is triggered. And that is what's creating this narrowing of awareness, this kind of detachment, lack of focus. It's what causes our heart rate to drop. It's your nervous system basically saying, if I can't, escape this, if I can't fight back against this, I'll just disconnect. And maybe I'll survive with a few less emotional scars, or at least with some energy for later. When we look at the brain, neuroimaging studies will show that something fascinating happens during this process. When people|||这是体内最长的神经。它是调节我们体内几乎每个系统（特别是我们的副交感神经系统，它能使事情减速、关闭事物）的主要通路。因此，当我们体验到解离时，该状态就会被触发。而这正是造成这种意识狭窄、这种疏离感、缺乏注意力的原因。正是它导致我们的心率下降。这基本上是你的神经系统在说：如果我无法逃脱这个，如果我无法反抗这个，我就会断开连接。也许我能带着少几个情感伤疤活下来，或者至少留点精力留待以后。当我们观察大脑时，神经成像研究将表明在此过程中发生了一件迷人的事情。当人们
with trauma-related or stress-related dissociation are reminded of distressing experiences or put into a stressed state, the amygdala, our brain's alarm, system often actually shows reduced activity compared to the intense activation that you would expect if someone was in a hyper aroused state. So this gets kind of complicated here, but how people respond to trauma is different. Some of them have hyperarousal, some of them have hypo arousal. So either you stay in this like cortisol fight or flight state and you are constantly hypervigionate or alert, or some people go this way and they stay in this dissociative or hypo-arousal state where they kind of just tune out and they feel completely disconnected. In those cases,
with trauma-related or stress-related dissociation are reminded of distressing experiences or put into a stressed state, the amygdala, our brain's alarm, system often actually shows reduced activity compared to the intense activation that you would expect if someone was in a hyper aroused state. So this gets kind of complicated here, but how people respond to trauma is different. Some of them have hyperarousal, some of them have hypo arousal. So either you stay in this like cortisol fight or flight state and you are constantly hypervigilant or alert, or some people go this way and they stay in this dissociative or hypo-arousal state where they kind of just tune out and they feel completely disconnected. In those cases,|||患有与创伤或压力相关的解离症的人被提醒想起痛苦的经历或置于压力状态下时，与如果某人处于过度觉醒状态时所期望的强烈激活相比，杏仁核（我们大脑的警报系统）实际上经常表现出活动减少。所以这里事情变得有点复杂，但是人们对创伤的反应是不同的。他们中的一些人有过度觉醒（hyperarousal），一些人有低度觉醒（hypo-arousal）。所以要么你保持这种皮质醇战斗或逃跑状态，并且你不断地高度警惕或保持警觉，或者有些人走这条路，他们保持这种解离或低度觉醒状态，他们基本上只是调低知觉并感觉完全脱节。在这些情况下，
the part of our brain that would usually be like, everything's on fire, like run, run, run. For people who are experiencing dissociation, perhaps more than others, it seems that that part of their brain, something's kind of not working. There's not as much communication going on. meanwhile there's another part of our brain that is important for integrating emotions and for regulating emotions and during this state it also goes quiet this is important because this is the prefrontal cortex that's responsible for these things when that goes offline we lose a lot of our sense of processing rational processing and a sense of like i'm here and this is happening now we can lose our sense of being present which is probably what's creating that
the part of our brain that would usually be like, everything's on fire, like run, run, run. For people who are experiencing dissociation, perhaps more than others, it seems that that part of their brain, something's kind of not working. There's not as much communication going on. meanwhile there's another part of our brain that is important for integrating emotions and for regulating emotions and during this state it also goes quiet this is important because this is the prefrontal cortex that's responsible for these things when that goes offline we lose a lot of our sense of processing rational processing and a sense of like i'm here and this is happening now we can lose our sense of being present which is probably what's creating that|||我们大脑中通常会表现得像“万物都在燃烧，快跑，快跑，快跑”的那部分，对于经历解离的人来说，也许比其他人更多，似乎他们大脑的那一部分，有什么东西有点失灵了。没有那么多的沟通在进行。与此同时，我们大脑中另一部分对整合情绪和调节情绪很重要的部分在此状态下也变得安静了，这很重要，因为这是负责这些事情的前额叶皮层，当它离线时，我们失去了很多处理理性加工的感觉以及一种“我在这里，事情正在此时此地发生”的感觉，我们可能会失去当下感，这大概就是造成这种
weird feeling. There's one final area of the brain that's involved and that is the insular cortex. This is basically your ability to introspect, your ability to feel your body, your body signals, to understand that you are here, and it also shows dampened activation during dissociation. So all of these things are kind of combining and when you dissociate, your brain is basically trying to re-root around a bunch of systems that have all walked out on you. It's trying to get to the place, the thought patterns, the thoughts on your brain are trying to get to the same place and there's a whole lot of roads that are not working. So it takes longer to get there and maybe those messages never get there. Our awareness of our bodies, of our emotions, of our sense of continuity, of our memories,
weird feeling. There's one final area of the brain that's involved and that is the insular cortex. This is basically your ability to introspect, your ability to feel your body, your body signals, to understand that you are here, and it also shows dampened activation during dissociation. So all of these things are kind of combining and when you dissociate, your brain is basically trying to re-root around a bunch of systems that have all walked out on you. It's trying to get to the place, the thought patterns, the thoughts on your brain are trying to get to the same place and there's a whole lot of roads that are not working. So it takes longer to get there and maybe those messages never get there. Our awareness of our bodies, of our emotions, of our sense of continuity, of our memories,|||怪异感觉的原因。还涉及大脑的最后一个区域，那就是脑岛皮层（insular cortex）。这基本上是你的内省能力，感受你的身体、你的身体信号的能力，去理解你在这里，它在解离期间也表现出激活减弱。所以所有这些事情都在某种程度上结合在一起，当你解离时，你的大脑基本上是在试图围绕着一群已经抛弃了你的系统重新路由。它试图到达那个地方，你大脑中的思维模式、想法正试图到达同一个地方，而有相当多的路是不通的。所以到达那里需要更长的时间，也许这些消息永远无法到达。我们对身体的意识、对情绪的意识、对连续感的意识、对记忆的意识，
they've all been switched off, flooded, overwhelmed, and again, it's this protective reflex that we have evolved as humans so that we can survive hard things. Research shows that healthy adults can experience dissociation, yes, because of trauma, but also because of really everyday, I don't want to say simple, but common things, intense anxiety, stress from conflict, from exams, from work, even when they're just exhausted. For example, a 2014 study published in the Journal of Behavior Therapy and Experimental Psychiatry
they've all been switched off, flooded, overwhelmed, and again, it's this protective reflex that we have evolved as humans so that we can survive hard things. Research shows that healthy adults can experience dissociation, yes, because of trauma, but also because of really everyday, I don't want to say simple, but common things, intense anxiety, stress from conflict, from exams, from work, even when they're just exhausted. For example, a 2014 study published in the Journal of Behavior Therapy and Experimental Psychiatry|||它们都被关闭了、淹没了、压垮了，再次强调，这是我们作为人类进化出来的保护性反射，这样我们才能在艰难的事情中生存下来。研究表明，健康的成年人确实会经历解离，这不仅是因为创伤，还因为非常日常的、我不想说是简单但却是常见的事情——强烈的焦虑、来自冲突、考试、工作的压力，甚至是当他们精疲力竭的时候。例如，2014年发表在《行为疗法与实验精神病学杂志》（Journal of Behavior Therapy and Experimental Psychiatry）上的一项研究
looked at a sample of 560 healthy participants who didn't have any serious mental health conditions, and they basically split them into two groups. Half of the participants were placed in the experimental condition. They were deprived of sleep for 36 hours. the other half had a super normal night's sleep. They then asked the participants to rate their levels of sleepiness, their mood symptoms, their dissociative symptoms. And what they found was that sleep deprivation alone can push people into a dissociative
looked at a sample of 560 healthy participants who didn't have any serious mental health conditions, and they basically split them into two groups. Half of the participants were placed in the experimental condition. They were deprived of sleep for 36 hours. the other half had a super normal night's sleep. They then asked the participants to rate their levels of sleepiness, their mood symptoms, their dissociative symptoms. And what they found was that sleep deprivation alone can push people into a dissociative|||调查了560名没有任何严重精神健康状况的健康参与者样本，他们基本上将这些人分为两组。一半的参与者被置于实验条件下。他们被剥夺睡眠36小时。另一半则睡了一个超级正常的觉。然后他们要求参与者评估他们的困倦程度、情绪症状、解离症状。他们发现，仅剥夺睡眠就能将人推向解离的
moment or state of mind. It can make them depersonalize or make them de-realize. So again, you're not going, and I'm going to use air quotes here, You can't see me use them, but you are not going crazy. Sometimes it's just that you are tired. You are overwhelmed. You are at a low. Your brain doesn't have the same cognitive, psychological, and mental resources that it usually would.
moment or state of mind. It can make them depersonalize or make them de-realization. So again, you're not going, and I'm going to use air quotes here, You can't see me use them, but you are not going crazy. Sometimes it's just that you are tired. You are overwhelmed. You are at a low. Your brain doesn't have the same cognitive, psychological, and mental resources that it usually would.|||时刻或精神状态。它能让他们人格解体或现实解体。所以再次强调，你没有——我在这里打个引号，你看不到我用它们——但你没有疯。有时只是因为你累了。你被压垮了。你正处于低谷。你的大脑没有平时拥有的同等认知、心理和精神资源。
So it just shuts things down. It will pass. These everyday stresses, they feel big, they feel scary. They're also typically short-lived. It's just that your nervous system doesn't discriminate. It's just trying to do what it's. meant to do. It has, it has like it's manual in front of it. It's reading from the manual and it's not very flexible. It's just, this is what I've been told to do. This is the systems that I have available to
So it just shuts things down. It will pass. These everyday stresses, they feel big, they feel scary. They're also typically short-lived. It's just that your nervous system doesn't discriminate. It's just trying to do what it's. meant to do. It has, it has like it's manual in front of it. It's reading from the manual and it's not very flexible. It's just, this is what I've been told to do. This is the systems that I have available to|||所以它只是关闭了各种系统。这会过去的。这些日常的压力，它们感觉很大，感觉很可怕。它们通常也是短暂的。只是你的神经系统不加区分。它只是在试图做它本该做的事。它有，它就像面前有一本手册。它照着手册读，而且不是很灵活。它只是觉得，这就是我被告知要去做的事。这就是我可用的系统。
me. They're feeling stressed. Okay, my manual tells me, press this button. That's what's happening to your brain right now. Okay, we're going to take a short break here. But when we return, I want to talk about the unique relationship between ADHD and dissociation as well as trauma and Association. Stay with us. We will be right back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the
me. They're feeling stressed. Okay, my manual tells me, press this button. That's what's happening to your brain right now. Okay, we're going to take a short break here. But when we return, I want to talk about the unique relationship between ADHD and dissociation as well as trauma and Association. Stay with us. We will be right back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the|||他们感到压力。好吧，我的手册告诉我，按下这个按钮。这就是你现在的大脑正在发生的事情。好吧，我们在这里休息一下。但当我们回来时，我想谈谈ADHD与解离之间独特的关系，以及创伤与解离的关系。请继续收听。我们马上回来。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越那些
impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio app.
impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio app.|||主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本身具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的。收听《2%》。这就是 iHeartRadio 应用上的 T-W-O-P-P-Cent。
Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.|||Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么鬼关系？好吧，你可以在《回首往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.|||每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备好谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，说到这里，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿始终的线索。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。然后你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing|||欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的个人经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西，
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid?
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid?|||而我们仍在追逐它，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要，还是因为你害怕才做一个好人？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,|||因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客中就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实对话，
Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.|||《迎难而上》。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索《迎难而上》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露出她故事中明显的不一致之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detection. detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detection. detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.|||这开启了一场历时数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你在某人身上两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探侦探来破获此案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.|||他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要面对后果了。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So something that you may not know, or maybe you do, I don't know what you do and don't know, but I certainly wasn't entirely over this idea, is that dissociation and ADHD are actually deeply linked. people with ADHD, for example, may find that everyday stresses are even more extreme,
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So something that you may not know, or maybe you do, I don't know what you do and don't know, but I certainly wasn't entirely over this idea, is that dissociation and ADHD are actually deeply linked. people with ADHD, for example, may find that everyday stresses are even more extreme,|||女士们先生们，马里科帕县（Maricopa County）突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。所以有一件事你可能不知道，或者你可能知道，我不知道你懂什么不懂什么，但我绝对没有完全摆脱这种想法，那就是解离和多动症（ADHD）实际上有着深刻的联系。例如，患有ADHD的人可能会发现日常压力更加极端，
meaning their brain has to rely on dissociation more. There's the sensory overload, there's like the cognitive load of having to juggle multiple tasks of shifting attention, remembering deadlines, managing impulses, plus the emotional dysregulation that people with ADHD can experience where small things trigger really big reactions. All of this adds up. The nervous system for someone with ADHD is constantly taxed. And when that combination of sensory, cognitive, and emotional demands reaches a tipping
meaning their brain has to rely on dissociation more. There's the sensory overload, there's like the cognitive load of having to juggle multiple tasks of shifting attention, remembering deadlines, managing impulses, plus the emotional dysregulation that people with ADHD can experience where small things trigger really big reactions. All of this adds up. The nervous system for someone with ADHD is constantly taxed. And when that combination of sensory, cognitive, and emotional demands reaches a tipping|||这意味着他们的大脑必须更多地依赖解离。有感官过载，还有必须同时处理多个任务、转移注意力、记住最后期限、管理冲动的认知负荷，再加上ADHD患者可能会经历的情绪失调（即小事情会引发非常大的反应）。所有这些加起来。对于患有ADHD的人来说，神经系统不断受到压榨。当这种感官、认知和情绪需求的结合达到一个转折点时，
point, the brain again, presses the button, activates the same protective mechanisms that we sometimes see as a trauma response, even if no trauma is actually present. Dissociation in the sense is not caused by ADHD itself, but it often, is something that a lot of people find themselves slipping into in these moments because it's just the only way to survive the overload. It's also worth noting that dissociation in ADHD, in particular, can be very, very subtle. So a lot of people don't always put this label on it. It might show up as zoning out a lot more, which people can get frustrated at you for, even though, you know, you're not deliberately trying to do it. Losing track of time whilst you're
point, the brain again, presses the button, activates the same protective mechanisms that we sometimes see as a trauma response, even if no trauma is actually present. Dissociation in the sense is not caused by ADHD itself, but it often, is something that a lot of people find themselves slipping into in these moments because it's just the only way to survive the overload. It's also worth noting that dissociation in ADHD, in particular, can be very, very subtle. So a lot of people don't always put this label on it. It might show up as zoning out a lot more, which people can get frustrated at you for, even though, you know, you're not deliberately trying to do it. Losing track of time whilst you're|||大脑再次按下按钮，激活了有时被我们视为创伤反应的相同保护机制，即使实际上并不存在创伤。从这个意义上说，解离并不是由ADHD本身引起的，但它通常是许多人在这些时刻发现自己会陷入其中的事情，因为这只是在过载中生存下来的唯一方法。同样值得注意的是，ADHD中的解离，尤其是，可能非常非常微妙。因此，很多人并不总是把这个标签贴在它上面。它可能表现为更多的走神，人们可能会为此对你感到沮丧，尽管你知道，你并不是故意要这样做的。当你……时失去时间感
hyper-focusing on a task. Some people have have labeled that as a form of dissociation or just feeling really, really numb during moments of high stress. Like someone is, you know, bringing something to you or someone is putting something on your plate that like needs to be done immediately and you just operate. You can just do it. This is like a weird skill that I have a couple friends with ADHD that they just seem to be able to do where it's like everyone else is freaking out and normally I would assume that they would be having the same if not a more emotional reaction and they just become like hyperfocused and they can just deal with it. This may be again because of this high reliance on dissociation. The brain can use it to its advantage during these
hyper-focusing on a task. Some people have have labeled that as a form of dissociation or just feeling really, really numb during moments of high stress. Like someone is, you know, bringing something to you or someone is putting something on your plate that like needs to be done immediately and you just operate. You can just do it. This is like a weird skill that I have a couple friends with ADHD that they just seem to be able to do where it's like everyone else is freaking out and normally I would assume that they would be having the same if not a more emotional reaction and they just become like hyperfocused and they can just deal with it. This may be again because of this high reliance on dissociation. The brain can use it to its advantage during these|||过度专注于某项任务。有些人将这标记为一种解离形式，或者只是在高压时刻感到非常非常麻木。就像有人，你知道的，给你拿来什么东西，或者有人把需要立即完成的事情放在你的盘子里，而你只是去操作。你就能做到。这就像是一种奇怪的技能，我有几个患有ADHD的朋友，他们似乎就是能做到这一点，就好像其他人都在抓狂，通常我会认为他们会有相同甚至更多的情绪反应，而他们却变得超级专注，并且能够直接处理它。这可能再次是因为对解离的高度依赖。大脑可以在这些时刻利用它来为自己谋取优势。
moments. There is also, of course, a link between dissociation and anxiety and depression and other mood disorders, but the biggest risk factor here, like the one that everyone is going to talk to you about if you mention dissociation in an academic room or in a room full of psychologists is trauma. Trauma. Trauma is the biggest thing that researchers will cite for you when it comes to dissociation. There was a recent report that suggests that the rates of dissociation are almost 60 to 70% higher in people who have experienced trauma than the average individual. That is one of the most replicated findings you will find from the last 50 years in psychology. Trauma and dissociation are like two peas in a pod. I feel like we've been talking about trauma a lot on the podcast recently,
moments. There is also, of course, a link between dissociation and anxiety and depression and other mood disorders, but the biggest risk factor here, like the one that everyone is going to talk to you about if you mention dissociation in an academic room or in a room full of psychologists is trauma. Trauma. Trauma is the biggest thing that researchers will cite for you when it comes to dissociation. There was a recent report that suggests that the rates of dissociation are almost 60 to 70% higher in people who have experienced trauma than the average individual. That is one of the most replicated findings you will find from the last 50 years in psychology. Trauma and dissociation are like two peas in a pod. I feel like we've been talking about trauma a lot on the podcast recently,|||当然，解离与焦虑、抑郁和其他情绪障碍之间也存在联系，但这里最大的风险因素，就像你在学术房间或充满心理学家的房间里提到解离时每个人都会跟你谈论的那样，是创伤。创伤。当谈到解离时，创伤是研究人员会为你列举的最大的事情。最近的一份报告表明，经历过创伤的人的解离率比普通人高出近60%到70%。这是你在过去50年的心理学中能找到的最具重复性的发现之一。创伤和解离就像是一枚硬币的两面。我觉得我们最近在播客里经常谈论创伤，
and just the hard parts of being human and how our brain and our bodies respond to that. It's been like a common theme for us in the last couple of months. I don't know if you've noticed. But I think it's because the deeper you get into the literature on these topics, the more you kind of realize how deeply shaped we are by the negative experiences that we may have and how the body instinctively holds onto these experiences for better or for worse in ways that do end up shaping our personality and how we respond to things without even knowing. Emotional abuse, neglect, inconsistent caregiving, but also childhood bullying,
and just the hard parts of being human and how our brain and our bodies respond to that. It's been like a common theme for us in the last couple of months. I don't know if you've noticed. But I think it's because the deeper you get into the literature on these topics, the more you kind of realize how deeply shaped we are by the negative experiences that we may have and how the body instinctively holds onto these experiences for better or for worse in ways that do end up shaping our personality and how we respond to things without even knowing. Emotional abuse, neglect, inconsistent caregiving, but also childhood bullying,|||以及做人的艰难之处，以及我们的大脑和身体是如何对此做出反应的。在过去的几个月里，这就像是我们的一个共同主题。我不知道你有没有注意到。但我认为这是因为你对这些主题的文献研究越深入，你就越会意识到，我们受可能经历过的负面经历的影响有多深，身体又是如何本能地为了好坏而紧抓着这些经历不放，以至于最终在不知不觉中塑造了我们的性格以及我们对事情的反应方式。情感虐待、忽视、不一致的照顾，还有童年霸凌，
surviving a natural disaster, surviving your parents' divorce. That can create a blueprint for dissociation later on in life. So there is this theory called the structural dissociation theory that explains why. According to this model, when a child experiences repeated overwhelming stress, you know, hearing their parents constantly fighting, being threatened by a caregiver, being at school seven to eight hours a day and feeling like they need to hide or, you know, have to look over their shoulder or are just constantly feeling out of place, their personality can actually split into what we call apparently normal parts or ANPs, which is what they use to handle daily life, and then emotional parts, EPs, which are the parts of them that store
surviving a natural disaster, surviving your parents' divorce. That can create a blueprint for dissociation later on in life. So there is this theory called the structural dissociation theory that explains why. According to this model, when a child experiences repeated overwhelming stress, you know, hearing their parents constantly fighting, being threatened by a caregiver, being at school seven to eight hours a day and feeling like they need to hide or, you know, have to look over their shoulder or are just constantly feeling out of place, their personality can actually split into what we call apparently normal parts or ANPs, which is what they use to handle daily life, and then emotional parts, EPs, which are the parts of them that store|||在自然灾害中幸存，在父母离异中幸存。这可能会为日后生活中的解离奠定蓝图。因此，有一个叫做结构性解离理论（structural dissociation theory）的理论解释了原因。根据这个模型，当一个孩子经历重复的压倒性压力时，你知道的，听到父母经常吵架、受到照顾者的威胁、一天在学校呆七到八个小时并觉得需要躲藏或者，你知道的，必须瞻前顾后或者总是觉得自己格格不入，他们的人格实际上可以分裂成我们所说的表观正常部分（ANPs），这是他们用来处理日常生活的部分，然后是情绪部分（EPs），也就是他们储存
the unprocessed trauma. The system learns to switch between these parts as a survival strategy. At school, you know, with a parent, the apparently normal parts, the ANPs will be on display. but then there are these emotional parts that are hidden away that they only briefly kind of dip into, that they don't really want to touch, their brain doesn't really want to touch, but is still there. In practice, this means that even as adults, people with this kind of history can experience dissociation when a trigger comes into their life that echoes the original trauma. A loud voice, a threatening tone, a situation where they feel powerless, even like, like relationship difficulties or conflict can cause people to be like, I know how to deal with this.
the unprocessed trauma. The system learns to switch between these parts as a survival strategy. At school, you know, with a parent, the apparently normal parts, the ANPs will be on display. but then there are these emotional parts that are hidden away that they only briefly kind of dip into, that they don't really want to touch, their brain doesn't really want to touch, but is still there. In practice, this means that even as adults, people with this kind of history can experience dissociation when a trigger comes into their life that echoes the original trauma. A loud voice, a threatening tone, a situation where they feel powerless, even like, like relationship difficulties or conflict can cause people to be like, I know how to deal with this.|||未处理创伤的部分。系统学会了在这些部分之间切换作为一种生存策略。在学校里，你知道的，和父母在一起时，表观正常部分（ANPs）会表现出来。但随后还有这些被隐藏起来的情绪部分，他们只是短暂地涉足其中，他们其实不想去触碰，他们的大脑其实不想去触碰，但它仍然在那里。在实践中，这意味着即使作为成年人，有这种历史的人在生活中出现呼应最初创伤的触发因素时，也会经历解离。响亮的声音、威胁的语气、感到无助的情境，甚至像，像人际关系困难或冲突，都会导致人们觉得：我知道该如何处理这个了。
I'll just slip this mask on. I'll just fade out of this and here in this state I can be safe, even if I feel completely weird. It's not that the present is objectively dangerous. It's just that the nervous system again recognizes an environmental cue that resembles past trauma. and these patterns from early life switch us into protective mode because what else is your body going to do? Just ignore when it thinks something dangerous is about to happen. That's not its programming. This is where dissociation can become really maladaptive when it's responding to threats that aren't there anymore
我只是戴上这个面具。我只是从中淡出，在这里，我可以感到安全，即使我感觉完全怪异。这并不是说现在客观上有危险。只是神经系统再次识别出了类似于过去创伤的环境线索。早年生活中的这些模式让我们进入了保护模式，因为你的身体还能怎么办？难道要去忽视它认为即将发生危险的时刻吗？它的程序里可没有这个。这就是解离为什么会变得非常不适应的原因，当它在对那些已经不存在的威胁做出反应时
or when it becomes the only strategy that our brain keeps going back to when things are scary and when better options are available for it. If your brain, again, learns that the early world is dangerous, and the only way to keep going through this is to put large parts of that experience offline or to kind of float above the world or float above yourself, those dissociative patterns can become stabilized. I was actually reading up on a bunch of cases about this in a couple of psychiatric journals just to see how this presented.
或者当它变成我们的神经在事情变得可怕时唯一不断回溯的策略，而当时其实有更好的选择可供它使用时。如果你的大脑再次了解到早期的世界是危险的，而继续下去的唯一方法就是让那段经历的大部分处于离线状态，或者某种程度上漂浮在世界之上，或者漂浮在你自己之上，那些解离的模式就会变得稳定下来。我最近实际上在几本精神病学期刊上阅读了大量关于这方面的案例，只是为了看看它是如何表现的。
and there was one case, actually there's a couple cases I'll read you that was super interesting. The first was of a young 21-year-old guy and he experienced a really bad dissociative episode when he got back in touch with his estranged father. And he dissociated for, I think it was like three or four days. He couldn't remember being admitted into a psychiatric hospital. He couldn't remember anything that had happened to him in the last three to four days of his life, despite being really, really healthy and otherwise completely fine. And afterwards, he told physicians that the last time this had happened to him
而且有一个案例，实际上有几个案例我要读给你们听，超级有趣。第一个是一个21岁的年轻小伙子，当他重新联系上疏远的父亲时，他经历了一次非常严重的解离发作。他解离了，我想大概有三四天。他不记得自己被送进了精神病院。他不记得在过去的生命中的三四天里发生在他身上的任何事情，尽管他非常非常健康，其他方面完全没问题。事后，他告诉医生，上一次发生这种事
was surprise, surprise, when he was a young kid and he'd last seen his father. You know, it'd been years, I think for him, and maybe it'd even been over a decade, since he'd seen his father. And yet he was right back there. And this ancient part of our brain is like, okay, I know what to do here. Another case I read was someone in their 50s who reported that at 24, it was like her life suddenly changed color. And she felt like everything became dampened after a serious traumatic event. And since then, she'd only had a few moments every year when she had felt normal.
不出所料，是当他还是个小孩子的时候，那时他最后一次见他的父亲。你知道的，对他来说已经有好几年了，我想甚至可能已经超过十年没见他父亲了。然而他又回到了那种状态。我们大脑中这个古老的部份就像是，好吧，我知道这里该怎么做了。我读到的另一个案例是一个50多岁的人，她报告说在24岁时，她的生活就像突然变了颜色。在经历了一次严重的创伤事件后，她觉得一切都变得黯淡了。从那以后，她每年只有短短的几个时刻会觉得自己是正常的。
But she actually was telling physicians that like she liked how she felt. She was like, I don't, I know it's a problem. My family tells me it's a problem, but I like this feeling of sometimes not feeling real or not feeling like the world is real or detaching myself from what's going on around me. It just feels more peaceful. Again, a maladaptive coping strategy. It's probably about time we bring up dissociative identity disorder and what we previously knew is multiple personality disorder. because when trauma is really extreme, there is this thing that can happen, this phenomena where someone's personality splits so deeply that they feel like they are different people at different times. Now, this is not everyday dissociation. This is not feeling unreal and panicked by that feeling.
但她实际上告诉医生，她其实挺喜欢这种感觉的。她说，我不知道，我知道这是个问题。我的家人告诉我这是个问题，但我喜欢这种有时感觉不真实，或者觉得世界不真实，或者把自己从周围发生的事情中抽离出来的感觉。那样感觉更平静。再次说明，这是一种不良的应对策略。现在可能是时候提出解离性身份障碍了，也就是我们以前所知的多重人格障碍。因为当创伤极其极端时，会发生这样一件事，这种现象是某个人的性格分裂得如此之深，以至于他们觉得自己在不同的时间是不同的人。现在，这并不是日常的解离。这并不是那种感到不真实并因此惊慌失措的感觉。
This is when children especially go through such a terrible thing in their life. that the only way they endure it is to say is to almost create an alter or a persona that it's happening to that is not them as a way to protect their ego. And those people, once they are created in their mind, it's very hard to kill them. Some people even have amnesia about this. There's an incredible YouTube video that I think you should watch titled, oh, okay, I need to remember, I think it's titled Living with Twelve Alternative Personality. for 60 years, and it interviews a woman called Amanda, who has 12 altars, 12 different
这是当孩子们尤其是经历过生活中如此可怕的事情时，他们忍受的唯一方式就是说，几乎是创造了一个承受这一切的替身或人格，而这个人格不是他们自己，以此来保护他们的自我。而这些人在他们的脑海中被创造出来后，很难将其抹去。有些人甚至对此有健忘症。有一个极其精彩的YouTube视频，我想你们应该去看一看，标题是，哦，好吧，我需要记一下，我想它的标题是《与十二个人格共同生活》
personalities that have emerged from and through traumatic periods in her life. Some of them are children, some of them are teenagers, some of them are men, some of them are women, some of them are older. And she switches between them sometimes on a daily, sometimes monthly. They feel like she's like, when I am in this person, I am this person. I don't have amnesia about it. Like, the way she tries to explain it is like someone trying to explain colors that don't exist. Like, you just probably can't see it or understand it unless you are her.
长达60年》，它采访了一位名叫阿曼达的女性，她拥有12个替身，12个不同的
And she describes the first time she experienced this as a child when something horrible happened to her. And she, again, was like, this is not happening to me. This is happening to Jenny. Hi, Jenny. And then Jenny was this part of her personality that, dissociated and broke off and she just kept relying on this strategy and kept splitting until she is the person she is today. What's so interesting and what I found so interesting about this video where she was like, they all have different opinions, they kind of have different voices,
她将这第一次经历描述为她还是个孩子时，当可怕的事情发生在她身上的时候。她再次感到，这不是发生在我身上。这是发生在珍妮身上的。嗨，珍妮。然后珍妮成了她人格中解离并分裂出去的一部分，她不断依赖这种策略并不断分裂，直到成为今天的自己。最有趣的是，也是我在这段视频中发现最有趣的是，她说，他们所有人都有不同的意见，他们有不同的声音，
they have different even political beliefs, different food preferences. And she even in this interview, like switches between her and I think the guy, like one of her personalities called Bradley, like on camera. And the reason I bring this, this extreme case up is because firstly I think it's important to see the level, like the maximum level at which this can develop to. It's almost comforting to know that like even if that was where I ended up or you ended up, like you would still be okay. This woman seems actually very happy and very loved. But also because in those unique cases, you really can see the anatomy of this mechanism. You can see exactly more clearly, I guess, what is happening to you. You are obviously not splitting into a different personality,
他们甚至有不同的政治信仰、不同的食物偏好。她甚至在这段采访中，在镜头前在她自己和我认为的那位男士之间切换，也就是她的一个人格，名叫布拉德利。我之所以提出这个极端的案例，是因为首先我认为看到这种发展可以达到的最高水平是很重要的。知道即使那是我的结局或是你的结局，你依然会安然无恙，这几乎是令人宽慰的。这位女士实际上看起来非常快乐，也备受关爱。但同时也是因为在那些独特的案例中，你确实可以看到这种机制的解剖结构。我想，你可以更清楚地看到究竟是什么在发生在你身上。你显然没有分裂成不同的人格，
but it's the same premise. Your brain just needs a break. It just needs to clock out for a little bit. I will say it's very unlikely that this will happen to you, especially if you are over the age of 12. you have to have experienced intense trauma in your childhood to be diagnosed with dissociative identity disorder. Obviously, some people get diagnosed later in life, but I think it's important to realize that these really intense cases are super rare. So if you are experiencing everyday dissociation, yes, it's really scary, but you're probably not going to end up in this extreme state and even if you do you will survive. You may have relied on dissociation for a long time without realizing it. It doesn't mean that you're always going to feel this way or be in this state.
但这其实是相同的逻辑。你的大脑只是需要休息一下。它只是需要暂时打卡下班一小会儿。我要说的是，这发生在你身上的可能性非常小，特别是如果你已经超过12岁的话。你必须在童年时期经历过严重的创伤，才会被诊断为解离性身份障碍。显然，有些人在生命的晚期才被诊断出来，但我认为重要的是要意识到这些极端的案例是非常罕见的。所以如果你正在经历日常的解离，是的，这真的很可怕，但你大概率不会陷入这种极端的心理状态，即使你真的经历了，你也能够挺过去。你可能在不知不觉中依赖解离很长一段时间了。这并不意味着你永远都会有这种感觉或处于这种状态。
The good news is that your nervous system is completely plastic, it is changeable. There is a way to switch off chronic dissociative responses and to really feel more in touch with reality and the feeling of being real and the feeling of being alive, even if maybe that is in itself equally, equally like confronting, it's good to know the possibility is there and that you can remove this filter over your experiences. And that's what we're going to talk about next. When dissociation feels scary, when depersonalization, de-realization takes over, how do you bring yourself back successfully? Stick around.
好消息是，你的神经系统具有完全的可塑性，它是可变的。有一种方法可以关闭长期的解离反应，让你真正重新与现实建立联系，找回真实感和活着的感觉，即使这种感觉本身可能同样令人感到对立和冲击，但知道这种可能性是存在的，并且你可以消除笼罩在经历之上的这层滤镜，是一件好事。而这正是我们接下来要讨论的内容。当解离让人感到害怕，当人格解体、现实解体占据上风时，你该如何成功地把自己拉回来？敬请期待。
We're going to talk about all of that and more. after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
在这段简短的广告之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、体能和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带你抛开主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们曾深信种子油本质上会导致发炎。我们大错特错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。还有我，亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一切的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为国会。
crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
快克可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊当天的快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这其中有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《用艰难的方式学习》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我说的就是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now.
而且那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我的新播客《用艰难的方式学习》，由我基尔·盖恩斯带你进行关于疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用。搜索“用艰难的方式学习”并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她说法中的明显矛盾。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人的故事。格雷格，蕾丝边，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要面对后果了。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In true psychology of your 20s fashion, I want to give you some strategies that might help if you have noticed in yourself that you have a tendency to not feel real, to not feel like the world is real, or to dissociate.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，
Like I said, this is something that I experience quite a bit, especially when I'm I'm sleep deprived, especially when I'm stressed, especially when I have a lot of my plate, I often find that I will have these like really scary moments right before I go to bed, where automatically my brain is like, oh, well, did you know that you're not actually real and that you're not actually here? And I'm like, can we, can we cut with, can we not with that? Like, I'm sick feeling this way. Like, let's, let's cut the cameras on that one. But I have actually discovered some really helpful strategies that like make me the boss of that feeling and immediately kind of shut it up to be like the most polite about it. You know, a lot of people talk about grounding,
就像我说的，这是我经常经历的事情，特别是当我睡眠不足时，特别是当我感到压力很大时，特别是当我手头有很多事情要处理时，我经常发现在我准备睡觉前的那些可怕时刻，大脑会自动觉得，哦，难道你不知道其实你并不是真实的，你其实并不在这里吗？我会想，我们能，我们能别这样吗，能别搞这出吗？真的，我厌倦了这种感觉。就像，让我们，让我们把摄像机停掉吧。但我确实发现了一些非常有用的小策略，能让我成为那种感觉的主人，并立即让它闭嘴，用最礼貌的方式来说。你知道，很多人都在谈论接地气，
you know, naming five things that you can see, hear, feel, maybe even taste, placing your feet on the grass, in the dirt, in the sand and really connecting with with the earth. Those are all great strategy is probably ones that we know and sometimes it just doesn't cut it. So here are some things that might take this to the next level for you and might actively be able to pull you back into the world when dissociation hits. The first being safety scaffolding. If dissociation happens, it really helps to have a predictable low effort ritual that signals safety to your nervous system.
你知道，说出五件你能看到、听到、感受到甚至尝到的东西，把你的双脚放在草地上、泥土里、沙子里，真正与大地建立连接。这些都是很好的策略，可能也是我们都知道的策略，但有时它们就是不管用。所以这里有一些方法，可能会将这一点提升到一个新的水平，当解离来袭时，能够主动把你拉回现实世界。第一种是安全脚手架。如果解离发生了，拥有一个可预测的、低精力的仪式真的很有帮助，它会向你的神经系统发出安全的信号。
That could be a short recorded audio that you've made of your own voice saying a really calming mantra or just saying, hey, I know you're not feeling real right now. I can promise you, you definitely are. It could also be the voice of someone else, like a meditation that you always come back to. The familiarity of the voice, whether it's your own or a voice that you listen to a lot, reduces the initial alarm state that you might be feeling because it signals, okay, something I know well and something I know to be true is here. I must be present because, this is something that I keep coming back to. This is something that has been continuous. This mantra from myself, this meditation has always been here through these moments.
那可能是一段你用自己的声音录制的简短音频，里面说着一段非常平静的咒语，或者只是说，嘿，我知道你现在感觉不真实。我向你保证，你绝对是真实的。它也可以是其他人的声音，比如你经常回听的冥想音频。声音的熟悉感，无论是你自己的声音还是你经常听的声音，都会降低你可能感受到的最初警报状态，因为它发出了这样的信号：好吧，我非常熟悉且知道是真实的东西就在这里。我一定在场，因为，这是我不断回归的事物。这是具有延续性的事物。我自己的这段咒语，这段冥想，在这些时刻一直都在这里。
It's just like having an anchor to hold on to. Another kind of scaffolding is anything sensory. A Rubik's Cube, a mint lozenge, chewing gum, something like that. I've also given this tip before, Warheads, sour candies, have been a lifesaver for me in these moments because the extreme sensory experience of this candy, it like genuinely shocks me and brings me back into the present because it's something that I cannot ignore. It is this like real thing that is like, of course you're alive because how could I be alive and be experiencing, oh, not be alive and be experiencing this like so intensely and it's just like the shock that just like catapults me right back to where my feet are planted.
这就像是抓紧了一个锚。另一种脚手架是任何感官方面的东西。魔方、薄荷润喉糖、口香糖，诸如此类。我也分享过这个诀窍，酸糖在这些时刻一直是我的救命稻草，因为这种糖带来的极端的感官体验，真的震撼了我，把我拉回了当下，因为这是我无法忽视的东西。它是一种真实的东西，仿佛在说，你怎么可能不是活着的呢，因为你怎么可能活着却在经历，哦，不是活着却在体验这种强烈的感觉，这就像是一个震动，把我直接 catapult（抛射）回双脚站立的地方。
I think it's also like a distraction technique. Like when you're chewing or licking or whatever consuming something that's that sour, sometimes you just like can't really think about anything else. And it lets you just for a moment stop thinking about thinking about not being real or the world not being real, if you know what I mean. I know as well that when I'm flying overseas, I will or flying anywhere. Like I will feel a sense of de-realization a lot more. so I also always bring something from home, like a little figurine from my house on every trip
我想这也是一种分散注意力的技术。就像当你咀嚼、舔舐或消费任何酸的东西时，有时你就是无法再去想别的事情。它让你能够哪怕仅仅片刻，停止去思考“自己不真实”或“世界不真实”这件事，如果你明白我的意思的话。我也知道，当我在海外飞行时，或者去任何地方飞行时。我会更频繁地感受到现实解离的抽离感。所以我每次旅行也总是会从家里带点东西，比如家里的一件小摆件，
that I just like set in my hotel room or like bring with me in my bag. And it has this weird therapeutic effect on me. I don't know what it is. But again, like I think especially being away from my environment that I love and that I cherish and like from my dog and like from my life, I can feel quite unstable. and having this like really otherwise quite silly stupid thing that would otherwise just be like this ornamental thing in my house with me on this trip pulls me back to that environment where I feel my safest. I've also heard of someone, a friend of mine who brings a sheet of stickers with her
我只会把它摆在酒店房间里，或者随身带在包里。它对我有一种奇怪的治疗效果。我不知道为什么。但同样地，我觉得特别是在远离我所爱、所珍惜的环境，远离我的狗和我的生活之后，我会感到相当不稳定。而拥有这个原本相当傻气、愚蠢的东西——它本应只是我家里的一个装饰品，却跟我一起踏上这段旅程——把我拉回了那个让我感觉最安全的环境。我还听说过一个人，我的一个朋友，她带着一页贴纸
everywhere she goes and any time she feels strange or she feels odd, she will pull out a sticker and it's like one of those 3D stickers like those squishy ones and she will like stick. and she will like stick one onto the wall or her computer or a mirror or like the back of the bus seat and just like focus on it. And she's like, oh, well, I'm bringing like, at least this thing is real. At least I have these stickers that I'm bringing with me in to every single different situation. And I know it sounds silly, but sometimes for something is like extreme and scary as de-realization, you just have to either beat it with complete reason or beat it with silliness and being a little bit goofy with it. And like playing with the feeling.
无论走到哪里都带着。每当她感到奇怪或不对劲时，她就会掏出一张贴纸——那是那种3D贴纸，像那种软绵绵的贴纸——然后她就会贴上去。她会把一张贴在墙上、电脑上、镜子上或者公交车座椅的背面，然后专心致志地看着它。她说，好吧，我带了，至少这个东西是真的。至少我随身带着这些贴纸，带到了每一个不同的情境中。我知道这听起来很傻，但有时对于像现实解离这样极端而可怕的事情，你只能要么用纯粹的理性去击败它，要么用傻气和一点点滑稽的态度去应对它，并把这种感觉当成游戏。
These are all kind of sensory or physical anchors. We can also use kinesthetic anchors, which is basically just a fancy word for moving your body, like, and really moving it. Don't just like look at your hands and feet as they, like, wriggle. That can still feel kind of disorientating. I want you to like fully, rapidly, violently, shake your whole body. Dance, stretch, move, run, just like spasm in the air. Do something that you feel reconnects you with your limbs and your fingers and your
这些都是某种感官或身体上的锚。我们还可以使用动觉锚，这其实只是一个fancy（花哨）的词，意思是移动你的身体，而且是真正地移动。不要只是看着你的双手和双脚在那里扭动。那仍然会让人感到有些迷失方向。我希望你能够完全、迅速地、剧烈地摇晃你的整个身体。跳舞、伸展、运动、奔跑，就像在空中痉挛一样。做一些能让你重新连接到你的四肢、手指和
toenails. A 2014 study that I particularly love explored how dance therapy specifically helps people exit to association when other things aren't working because it creates kinesthetic awareness. And this is our body's natural ability to detect and locate and recognize our body, our form in space and time and our surroundings. and that kinesthetic awareness really activates something mentally within us as well that obviously recognizes that we must be present to be having this feeling and so it brings us back to our sense of realness. Even like repetitive rhythmic movements like bouncing your knee or rolling your
脚趾的事情。我特别喜欢2014年的一项研究，它探讨了舞蹈疗法是如何专门帮助人们在其他方法不管用时摆脱解离的，因为它创造了动觉意识。这是我们身体的自然能力，能够检测、定位和识别我们的身体、我们的形态在时间和空间以及周围环境中的位置。这种动觉意识也会在精神上激活我们内心深处的某种东西，显而易见，它让我们认识到我们必须在场才能有这种感觉，从而把我们带回真实感中。甚至像重复性的有节奏的运动，比如抖动膝盖或转动
shoulders or flowing, moving your body have been shown to provide that same grounding experience. It positions you back in the room. It shows you that you are in control, that you can feel time and space and movement around you. It also helps you obviously release tension. We know that stress is like a big trigger for dissociation. Sometimes that might also be why this mechanism works. I will also say,
双肩，或者流畅地移动你的身体，都被证明能提供那种相同的接地体验。它把你重新安置在房间里。它向你展示你是处于控制之中的，你能感受到你周身的时间、空间和运动。它显然也帮你释放了压力。我们知道压力是解离的一个巨大触发因素。有时这也是这种机制起作用的原因。我还要说的是，
sometimes you don't want to think even more about the feeling, but it's kind of liberating. to argue with it, to argue with the I'm not real, I'm not here thought. If your mind is saying that I'm not real, this isn't real, whatever it is, this may sound counterintuitive, but I think about how liberating that maybe would be if that was true. Like I know that this thought is scary to me, but I argue with the thought and I think, but what if that was a good thing?
有时你可能甚至不想再去深入思考这种感觉，但与它争辩——与“我不是真的”、“我不在这里”这种想法争辩——其实是一种解放。如果你的大脑在说我不是真的、这不是真的，无论是什么，这听起来可能有点反直觉，但我会去想，如果这是真的，那该有多解放啊。我知道这个想法对我很可怕，但我会与这个想法争辩，并心想，但如果这是一件好事呢？
let me explain. Like, if I wasn't real, it meant that something would have to be controlling this experience. And that makes me feel assured in the idea that something is out there that is bigger than us. And that's actually deeply comforting. And it's like, you were trying to scare me with this feeling. Actually, a part of it might be deeply, like, existentially validating. Or, you know, another thought that we have, like, I'm not actually here. well then that's fucking great that eliminates a lot of my social anxiety doesn't it why am i so
让我解释一下。如果我不是真的，那就意味着有什么东西在控制着这种体验。这让我确信这样一种观念：某种比我们更伟大的力量存在于外部。这其实是非常深得安慰的。这就好比，你试图用这种感觉来吓唬我。实际上，其中的一部分可能在存在主义层面上具有深深的认可感。或者，你知道，我们脑海中的另一个想法，比如，我其实并不在这里。那这可太棒了，这消除了我很多社交焦虑，不是吗？为什么我要这么
worried about being perceived if i'm not even real if the perception of me isn't even happening sometimes that's just like helpful to like turn off the anxiousness tap before i come back down and realize like firstly that this feeling is quite silly and to challenge it but also to say that like even if this was the case is that even a bad thing because my anxiety and my panic that is rising in response to my depersonalization or my de-realization is only rising because it is perceiving it is a terrible, terrifying thing. What if it wasn't? These are actually, they have a name.
担心被别人看作怎样，如果我甚至都不是真的，如果对我的感知甚至都没有发生的话？有时，这只是有助于在清醒过来并意识到——首先这种感觉挺傻的，并且要去挑战它——之前，关掉焦虑的水龙头。但同时也要说，即使真是这样，这甚至算是一件坏事吗？因为随着我的解离或现实解离而升起的焦虑和恐慌，之所以升起，只是因为它觉得这是一件极其可怕、恐怖的事情。如果事实并非如此呢？这些其实都是有名字的。
They're called cognitive scripts. They have been proven to help with this feeling. Another really famous one that you've probably heard comes from the philosopher, Renee Descartes, which says, I think, therefore I am, also a Billy Eilish song. basically this phrase, this mantra, I think therefore I am, tells us that the very act of doubting your own existence actually proves that you exist. How? Because to doubt, you have to be thinking and thinking is something that only a conscious mind
它们被称为认知脚本。事实证明，这些脚本有助于应对这种感觉。另一个你可能听说过的非常著名的观点来自哲学家勒内·笛卡尔，他说：“我思故我在”，这也是比利·艾利什的一首歌。基本上，这个短语、这句咒语“我思故我在”告诉我们，怀疑自己存在的这个行为本身，恰恰证明了你的存在。怎么证明？因为要想怀疑，你就必须在思考，而思考是只有有意识的头脑
can do. The very act of questioning, am I real? Is this real? Is proof that you are? And I know if this feels a little bit meta. but that's the reasuring part. The fact that you are noticing that you are dissociating, that you are questioning reality, that is all proof that you must be existing in order to have those thoughts.
才能做到的事情。质疑“我是真的吗？这是真的吗？”这个行为本身，就是你存在的证明。我知道这听起来可能有点形而上学。但这就是让人安心的部分。你注意到自己正在解离，你正在质疑现实，这一切都是证据，证明你必须存在才能产生那些想法。
Even when it feels like the world is fuzzy or your awareness isn't in itself a solid anchor, this in itself is like something we can always come back to. It's this subtle cognitive reminder that you may feel disconnected. that's just your individual experience. It doesn't mean that reality itself or the world around you has disappeared. It's just a natural response to stress. It's a natural response to perhaps trauma in your past, but even just not getting enough sleep, even just having a really hard day. I want to again remind you this whole process of feeling like everything is kind of blurring out or fuzzy or not real. is your brain trying to just give you a bit of a break and cut you some slack?
即使当世界感觉模模糊糊，或者你的意识本身并不是一个坚固的锚时，这一点本身就像是我们随时可以回溯的东西。这是一个微妙的认知提醒，提醒你可能感到与世隔绝，但这只是你个人的体验。这并不意味着现实本身或你周围的世界已经消失了。这只是对压力的自然反应。这可能是对你过去创伤的自然反应，但也可能仅仅是因为睡眠不足，或者仅仅是因为过了艰难的一天。我想再次提醒你，这种感觉一切都在变模糊、变得不真实或虚无的整个过程，其实是你的大脑在试图给你一点喘息的机会，对你网开一面？
It definitely doesn't feel nice. It doesn't mean that it's wrong. And it doesn't mean that something is wrong with you. Or that something is, this is an indicator of something dangerous that's going to happen to you. I think this is a gentle reminder that this is a human process. This is just noise. your brain isn't betraying you.
这绝对感觉不好受。但这并不意味着它是错的。这也不意味着你出了什么毛病。或者这预示着什么危险的事情将要降临到你身上。我认为这是一个温柔的提醒，提醒这是一种人类共有的生理过程。这只是一些噪音。你的大脑并没有背叛你。
It's not trying to tell you something. It's just trying to help you survive. You are real. You are here. I promise you that. You are listening to my voice in your ears right now. That is confirmation. And you're going to survive this.
它并不是在试图向你传达什么。它只是在试图帮助你生存下去。你是真实的。你就在这里。我向你保证。你此刻正在聆听我灌入你耳中的声音。这就是确认。你一定会熬过这一关的。
You're going to survive this overwhelm. I know it can feel super unpleasant. But everyone who has been through this, which is if the estimate's saying, nearly every person on this planet has come through on the other side. And if the worst case is that you are not real or the world isn't real, actually, that's not even a bad thing necessarily. You will still be okay.
你会挺过这种不知所措的焦虑。我知道这感觉超级不愉快。但每一个经历过这一切的人——如果估计准确的话，地球上几乎每个人——都从另一端走了过来。如果最坏的情况是你不是真的，或者世界不是真的，事实上，这甚至不一定是一件坏事。你依然会没事的。
You can still trust yourself to get through that. It's not even like that is the case. Like when you start to really question it, like you see how ridiculous it is, but even the most ridiculous fears aren't really that scary if they were to actually come true. and they won't even. So you're good on both fronts. Okay, I think that's all we have time for today. I hope you enjoyed this episode. I hope you learned something. I hope it felt validating. I hope that it's something you can come back to when you are feeling that same like airy, scary, panicked feeling of not being here. We've all been there. Well, at least I can say I most certainly have and I have made
你仍然可以相信自己能够挺过去。情况甚至根本不是那样的。当你开始真正去质疑它时，你就会发现它是多么荒谬，但即使是最荒谬的恐惧，如果真的成真了，其实也没有那么可怕。而且它们甚至根本不会成真。所以你在两方面都安全了。好了，我想我们今天的时间就到这里。希望你喜欢这一集。希望你有所收获。希望这能带给你认同感。希望当你再次感受到那种虚无的、可怕的、恐慌的“不在这里”的感觉时，这是一个你可以回味和求助的地方。我们都经历过。好吧，至少我可以肯定地说我经历过，而且我已经
it through. So I hope my strategies are helpful as well. I want to thank our research assistant Libby Colbert for her excellent help in providing some research assistance for this episode. She does an amazing job every single week time after time. So thank you, Libby. We also, a couple of updates now. We have a substack. If you've ever wanted a script for an episode or a transcript, we have one of those available on our substack.
挺过来了。所以我希望我的策略也能对你有所帮助。我要感谢我们的研究助理莉比·科尔伯特，感谢她在为本期节目提供研究协助方面所做出的出色工作。她每周都做得非常棒，一次又一次。所以，谢谢你，莉比。另外，我们还有几个更新。我们有一个Substack。如果你曾经想要某一集的文稿或文字记录，我们可以在Substack上提供。
You can go and subscribe. And we have a YouTube channel. Every second episode, every episode on Friday is a video episode that you can go and access there. I don't really talk about it enough, but I probably should. So if watching podcast is more your thing, that's now an opportunity. That's now an option for you. Make sure as well that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. You can send me a DM with further questions or like queries or episode suggestions over there. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Remember, I promise you are real, I promise you are present,
你可以去订阅。我们还有一个YouTube频道。每一集节目，周五播出的每一集都是视频节目，你可以在那里观看。我平时说的可能还不够多，但我大概应该多提提。所以，如果观看播客更适合你的风格，现在这就是一个机会。现在这也是你的一个选项。同时也请确保在Instagram上关注我们@That Psychology Podcast。你可以在那里给我发私信，提出更多的问题、疑问或节目建议。但直到下一次，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。记住，我向你保证你是真实的，我向你保证你在场，
I promise this is real. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我向我们所经历的这一切都是真实的。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《用艰难的方式学习》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都绝对不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《用艰难的方式学习》。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、体能和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO%”。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast.
当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。听女友们的话。相信我，宝贝，在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女友们，相信我》。在《回顾过去》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。还有我，亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一切的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。